me and my best friend Eric are going on
a cruise it's me and my wife are trying
to have kids when it happens it might be
kind of hard to have bro ventures so
this is one last ride off into the
sunset before your life changes forever
I am terrified of having a child Eric's
my neighbor growing up my best friend
for years he's the best man at my
wedding and I haven't seen him in like
two years so this is huge
should be somewhere near here good we're
back baby when we get together we never
know what's gonna know right
grab the throttle take it and shove it
down but you know responsibly of course
[Music]
the world is about to end only one man
can stop two men our room is pretty
awesome let's give you a quick tour of
all the features cue the rap music and
this wind is doing great things to my
hair feel great things of mine today
[Music]
this is it
[Music]
it's been pretty fun so far I feel like
I had all these misconceptions by
tomorrow and that's gonna realize we
should have been doing this 15 years ago
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I know that if I have a baby my life's
gonna change but hope it hasn't changed
too much I feel like you know they'll be
a lot of things that are different but I
don't think it's that crazy changing
something yeah yeah it's been done
before
yeah it might actually bring a lot of us
closer together
no tonight Eric and I are at the steak
house
I don't think I've ever had I've had
escargot either I think we would've
right weird like sophisticated honking
policy magenta
well there's Cheers you like garlic it's
like a savory gusher
escargot more like as car yeah it's a
lamb chop it looks like a pineapple
Cheers that is something if you serve
this at that like a fancy dinner at home
people be like damn
let's get into this lobster it's so
light and fluffy in here yeah right
this was so like yeah heavy al it was
like a tuba marching down I was like a
little clarinet doing a jazz routine
wine on my tongue clear some space for
this cancel my meetings did I leave room
for this no will I make room for this
yes it's a very we should not be doing
this but we should if I toss this out
would you be able to catch it
oh definitely all right
[Music]
yeah it's gonna be a fun day kind of
funny wake up in the morning in the
Caribbean
[Music]
[Music]
let's go three two one but I don't know
if this trip has made me anymore
ready to have a kid but it has given me
some fun ideas of what we could do with
a kid oh yeah you babysit baby Fulmer we
might go into town he'll be on those
little sacks on my chest
we'll get tie-dye shirts I mean he's
gonna look good in tanks - it's nice
gonna be fun we're going to Nick Jones
concert we're gonna go out you talk
you're going out we're staying on the
ship
but then we're also going out I just
love music so much awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
might have lost our voices a little bit
after the concert we sang some more
that's more drinks fair and then it's
time to dance so we kind of invented
some new dance moves when you go full
throttle too much
I'm sure engine runs out I wonder who
has more dots near you okay I was
turning even our massage into a
competition yeah you're gonna be a great
dad Eric whenever we go on trips
together that's very hurting myself like
we get kind of bored was enough things
to do but it was almost like we didn't
get to try everything I mean it's kind
of like a floating vacation you got me
in shuffleboard yes you got me in
basketball you know what we were tied
with all of our daytime activities but
Eric won the booty-shaking contest you
taught me how to do I don't know that
this trip is maybe anymore ready to
become a dad that sure was a lot of fun
this was a fun lots Rob I hope it's not
our last adventure yeah I'll be looking
for that text on a random Thursday can
you drop everything and watch my kids
I'll have my tank tops in the back of my
closet ready this bunch down break this
glass in case of cruise